you went on a Twitter tirade recently
now a lot of people are doing that these
days because they're angry about
politics so depending on what side
they're on they're going against the
President or they're going against
people that are going against the
president and there's just a lot of
anger out there
yours was unique you went on a Twitter
tirade about birds yeah bird man oh I
don't hate Birds age ranges are jerks
you know yeah like what are you talking
about like have you like if I asked you
to name like five cool birds you'd be
you'd like fizzle out at three
you'd be like Eagle Hawk Falcon and you
be like a finch yeah they're lame trying
to sleep and they will just keep on
chirping so I was like oh got on Twitter
I was like oh yeah you went off on Birds
yeah and we have it let's check this out
this is absurd foolish [ __ ] this
next one I just can't believe take a
gander at why those are beautiful
beautiful they're not hurting anybody
hollow boned morons yeah has anyone do
people get mad at you and you go after
Birds yeah I mean yes but I mean if
you're if your main thing is to go after
people were going after birds on Twitter
then that's automatic say you're yeah
okay so what you're doing is you're
trying to see if anyone can work up the
nerve to go after you for going after
bird yeah exactly it's it's a waste of
everyone's
[Laughter]
you